[Music]
today's question comes from jermaine in
florida
why pay off collections if your credit
score debt and taking loans goes against
your
teachings
i gotta read that one again
why pay off collections if your credit
score
debt and taking loans goes against your
teachings what is he asking there
well he's asking why pay off your
debt you know he does he's not if you're
not worried about your credit score and
just let it run up well it's not about
the credit score here
yeah so what amounts to is jermaine
you're picking and choosing which of our
teachings you like
in order to do something stupid so let
me help you the teaching number one is
the number one correlating character
quality to people who build wealth is
extreme levels of integrity
you're not representing that in your
question very well
so integrity says if you have debt in
collections that you go
settle it if you're broke you offer them
a settlement of some kind and we teach
people how to do that regularly or a
settlement if the
uh fees and other things added to it are
unreasonable
and out of control crazy like double
triple quadruple that kind of thing
um but you know you got a 250 medical
bill there where you actually went to
the doctor and you did 250 you need to
just pay your bill jermaine
that's why
yeah this does not go against our
teachings to pay off your debt that is
in fact what we teach uh and we're not
concerned about the credit score nowhere
do we say pay off collections so that
your credit score doesn't take a dip uh
we we are not concerned with that but
like dave saying it's the integrity
factor here you took out this debt we
believe you should pay it back
it does help your credit score though
sure because the collection's standing
against your credit score but if you're
not worried about your credit score
because you don't borrow money anymore
per our teachings then his point is why
bother and pay them off why go clean it
up because you owe the money and because
it's your electronic reputation and you
need to spend some effort
um and a bad credit score can hurt you
in certain situations so we like no
score and that's what happens when you
pay off all of your debt but with it
sitting in collections out there that's
not going to be a pretty situation if
for some reason they needed to pull that
score and they go
no you're not going to get no score is
preferable uh bad score you can live
with if you never try to borrow money or
never try to do anything where they're
pulling your credit score but um i'm not
trying to get you off the grid
um i'm just trying to get you where
you're not dependent on debt as your
source
that's the thing and so that's where you
misunderstood and
again i think you're picking and
choosing which of our
teachings because we've always taught
people to pay their bills
if at all possible if you have the money
if you can find the money if you can
work extra if you can sell stuff pay
your bills we want you to pay your bills
because that's what's best for you in
the long run
and again the number one correlating
character quality of people that are
able to build wealth and win is extreme
fanatical levels of integrity
so that's what you're you know that's
what you're aiming for